euh nous allons nous allons débuter
parce que effectivement le ministre doit
nous quitter pour 17h30 et puis je pense
il y a un écho là et je pense que vous
avez aussi toutes et tous des trains des
avions et à prendre pour rentrer pour
rentrer chez vous monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues nous avons le
plaisir d'accueillir pour ouvrir le
cycle des incontournables auditions
budgétaires monsieur Clément baun
ministre délégué auprès du ministre de
la transition écologique de la cohésion
des territoires chargé des trans
monsieur le ministre avant d'entrer dans
le détail du volet du projet de loi de
finance nous sommes bien dans le projet
de loi de finance pour 2024 relatif au
transport je souhaite aborder la
question de la révision de la
trajectoire d'investissement de l'État
en faveur des infrastructures de
transport prévu par la loi d'orientation
des mobilités laalom un sujet qui tient
à cœur aux membres de notre commission
rappelons que l'article 3 de la Lom
prévoyait une actualisation de cette
trajectoire au plus tard avant le 30
juin 2023 puis tous les 5 ans cette
échéance est à présent dépassée et
l'actualité de l'année 2023 a confirmé
l'obsolescence de la trajectoire
élaborée en 2019 dans la foulée de la
remise du rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures en
février dernier qui a proposé plusieurs
scénaris de programmation en matière
d'infrastructure de transport à
l'horizon
2042 la première ministre a annoncé le
plan d'avenir pour les transports don la
régénération la modernisation et le
développement des transport ainsi que le
soutien à l'intermodalité seront des
axes majeurs la mise en œuvre de cette
nouvelle feuille de route a d'ailleurs
déjà commencé j'en veux pour preuve que
notre commission vient d'examiner la
proposition de loi relative relative au
services express régionaux métropolitain
cerme comme l'a rappelé philippe Tabarot
rapporteur de ce texte dans notre
assemblée le choc d'offre en matière de
transport collectif que ce texte propose
de provoquer dans 10 métropoles
nécessitera des investissements majeurs
les n'a pourtant pas encore précisé
l'ampleur de son engagement financier
sur ce sujet or les acteurs réclament
une visibilité de long terme concernant
la trajectoire d'investissement de
l'État en matière d'infrastructure de
transport à commencé par laffit France
et les collectivités territoriales
surtout il est urgent de mettre en
trajectoire et en cohérence avec les
objectifs et priorités déjà annoncé par
la par le gouvernement dès lors monsieur
le ministre on est la préparation de la
révision de la trajectoire financière de
la Lom s'agissant des des modalités de
cette révision envisagez-vous de passer
par une loi portant spécifiquement sur
les infrastructures de transport une
l'OM 2 ou encore par un autre véhicule
législatif qui ne serait pas spécifique
au transport avez-vous d'ors et déjà une
idée du calendrier de l'examen de ce
futur texte j'en viens au sujet qui nous
réunit cet après-midi le projet de loi
de finances pour 2024 les trois
rapporteurs pour avis des transports
vous interrogeront tout à l'heure sur
les dispositions qui concernent euh
leurs secteurs respectifs je souhaite
quant à moi vous entendre sur l'article
15 du texte qui a une portée plus
transversale cet article vise à
instaurer une taxe sur l'exploitation
des infrastructures de transport de
longue distance à laquelle seraiit
assujettis les entreprises dont les
revenus d'exploitation excède 120
millions d'euros par an si le dispositif
concerne en principe tous les modes de
transport son exposer des motifs
indiquent qu'en pratique la taxe pèsera
uniquement sur les sociétés
concessionnaires a d'autoroute et sur
les plus grands aéroports pouvez-vous
préciser le champ le champ des acteurs
concernés par cette nouvelle taxe est-il
certain qu'elle n'aura pas de
répercussion sur les modes massifiés que
sont les modes ferroviaires et le mode
fluvial dans le prolongement de cette
question et du cycle d'audition mené par
notre commission avant l'été sur
l'avenir des concessions autoroutières
je souhaite évoquer la fin des contrats
de concession dont la première échéance
est prévue dès
2031 l'état dispose de peu de temps pour
mener à bien ce chantier d'ampleur tout
d'abord pourriez-vous nous indiquer où
en sont les travaux s'agissant de la
définition du bon état de retour des
infrastructure au concédant dans son
rapport de 2023 sur l'économie des
concessions autoroutières l'Autorité de
régulation des Transport a rappelé
l'importance de cette question pour
assurer la continuité du service
autoroutier par-dà la fin des contrats
en cours s'agissant de la préparation
des futurs contrats le régulateur a
recommandé dans ce rapport de Ré rejet
certains postulats du mode concessif
actuel d'une durée de 20 en particulier
il préconise de recourir à des contrat
plus court d'une durée de 20 ans pour
permettre une remise en concurrence plus
régulière à défaut de raccourcissement
de la durée des futurs contractants la
RT préconise un renforcement de la
régulation à travers une revue
périodique des paramètres des contrats
et le renforcement des pouvoirs du
régulateur qui pourra rendre des avis
plus contraignants quel est l'état de la
réflexion du gouvernement s'agissant des
modalités des futurs contrats concessifs
et quel regard portez-vous sur cette
proposition pour terminer je
souhaiteraiis vous interroger sur
l'avenir du fret ferroviaire dans notre
pays il s'agit comme vous le savez d'une
préoccupation préoccupation majeure pour
notre commission qui conduit un cycle
d'audition sur ce sujet dans le contexte
de la procédure engagée par la
Commission européenne sur les conditions
de financement de fret SNCF sur la
période
2007-2019 nous inquiétons de l'avenir de
fret CSF et au-delà des conséquences de
procédure pour le fret ferroviaire qui
semblait pourtant enfin renoué avec une
dynamique positive aussi monsieur le
ministre pour YZ nous faire un état des
lieux des discussions en cours sur
l'avenir de fret SNCF et sur les
modalités du plan de discontinuité
envisagé je ne serez pas plus long et
vous cède dès à présent la parole
monsieur Tabarot Deidi et gilet
rapporteur pour avis sur le volet
transport du PLF pour 2024 pour ensuite
vous interroger de même que l'ensemble
de nos collègues qui souhaitent le faire
tout en vous rappelant que nous devons
lever la séance pour 17h30 ce qui pour
certains vous arrangeront pour retourner
dans vos départements merci monsieur le
ministre je vous donne la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je comprends que cette
contrainte d'horaire est est partagée et
que elle
m'oblige en contradiction avec mes
habitudes les plus regrettables à être
concis euh tant mieux euh monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je suis heureux de pouvoir me
retrouver à nouveau devant vous pour
évoquer les questions que vous avez posé
bien évidemment et plus largement ce
contexte budgétaire du projet de loi de
finance pour 2024 je vais tâcher de
répondre à l'ensemble de ces sujets en
donnant peut-être si vous le permettez
un petit aperçu des grandes priorités de
ce projet de loi de finance puisque
comme vous l'avez évoqué j'y reviendrai
il est important depuis la loi
d'orientation des mobilités de garder
une perspective pluriannuelle et
complète sur l'investissement de l'État
en matière de transport c'est un projet
de loi de finance qui sera ici débattu
dans peu de jours qui euh marque une
très forte augmentation des moyens
consacrés au transport je me permets d'y
insister j'avais euh présenté pour ce
qui me concerne mon premier budget de
transports des transports l'an dernier à
peu près à la même époque devant vous et
c'était un budget qui était en
augmentation de 13 % par rapport à
l'année précédente la hausse entre le
projet de loi de finances entre la loi
de finance pardon pour 2023 et le projet
de loi de finance pour 2024 tel qu'il
vous est proposé est aussi de 13 % ce
qui veut dire qu'en 2 ans sur le
périmètre de l'ensemble des engagements
financiers de l'État en matière de
mobilité c'est une augmentation de près
de 30 % pour les transports vous le
savez la première ministre a annoncé
dans le cadre de la planification
écologique un renforcement des moyens
consacrés à la transition écologique de
7 milliards d'euros en crédit de
paiement 10 milliards d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement sur cette
hausse de 7 milliards d'euros les
transports représentent la plus
importante avec 1,6 milliard d'euros de
hausse c'est cela qui se retrouve dans
le PLF 2024 sur le périmètre consolidé
que j'évoquais puisque comme vous le
savez la vision d'ensemble n'est pas
toujours facile à restituer puisqu'il y
a à la fois le programme budgétaire le
plus directement concerné le programme
203 et puis d'autres outils budgétaires
qui sont dans le budget lui-même ou dans
les satellites de l'État si je puis le
présenter ainsi à la fois d'autres
programmes je pense au bonus écologique
par exemple je pense aux aides à
l'aéronautique d'autre part et puis je
pense à l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures à la Société du Grand
Paris à certains budgets annexes et cet
effort complet qui représente pour le
PLF 2024 une proposition de 13,6
milliards d'euros de crédit donc encore
une fois une hausse de près de 30 % par
rapport à ce qu'il était il y a 2 ans
c'est un budget qui essae qui je crois
il parvient de se concentrer sur les
grandes priorités que que j'avais
décrite devant vous lors de mon arrivée
à la fois les transports du quotidien et
la décarbonation des transports de
manière transversale je ne m'étonnerai
pas sur tous les chiffres mais quand on
regarde cet effort global d'environ 13
13 milliards et demi d'euros pour
arrondir il y a 8 milliards d'euros qui
sont directement consacré aux mobilités
vertees principalement les transports
ferroviaires et collectifs mais aussi le
transport fluvial ou l'effort national
en faveur du vélo 2 milliards d'euros
qui sont consacrés au verdissement de
secteurs fortement émetteurs ou
fortement polluant je pense évidemment à
l'aérien et à la route et le reste qui
est consacré à la modernisation du
réseau routier c'est un point sur lequel
le Sénat et je le sais très engagé très
vigilant et puis environ 1 milliard
d'euros qui est consacré à travers un
budget annexe à la modernisation et à la
sécurité de la navigation aérienne qui
est évidemment absolument prioritaire
avec des investissements qui sont
importants et qui nous remettront je le
crois au bon niveau en matière
d'investissement et de sécurité dans
notre contrôle aérien si
je zoome un un petit peu plus sur les
grandes priorités que j'avais évoqué
au-delà de la décarbonation et les
transports du quotidien c'est évidemment
une priorité qui est donnée au
ferroviaire je l'avais dit à plusieurs
reprises devant votre commission dès
l'an dernier ça se traduit dans les
priorités budgétaire pour le programme
203 qui est le cœur des crédits
budgétaires du ministère des Transports
c'est 85 % du total budgétaire qui est
consacré au transport ferroviair et au
transport collectif c'est essentiel et
si je reviens sur quelques grands objets
au sein de cette priorité ferroviaire je
serai bref et j reviendrai sans doute
dans notre échange ensuite je voudrais
insister en premier lieu sur la
régénération et la modernisation du
réseau ferroviaire qui est absolument
crucial qui je l'ai souvent dit est
invisible mais nous rattrape quand on
invvestit pas assez nous avons
aujourd'hui un niveau d'investissement
qui est le plus important depuis
plusieurs décennies avec 3 milliards
d'euros atints l'an dernier pour notre
réseau ferroviaire et c'est l'engagement
de la première ministre vous le savez
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs de monter ce
montant d'augmenter ce montant à 4,5
milliards d'euros donc 50 %
d'augmentation par étape opérationnelle
puisque les travaux se programment d'ici
la fin de la législature donc en 2027
cette année ce seront 300 millions
d'euros supplémentaires qui sont
consacrés à la régénération ferroviaire
je reviendrai sur le mode de financement
qui l'année prochaine sera très
vraisemblablement prise en charge par le
groupe SNCF contte tenu de ses résultats
au lieu de donner dividende à l'état il
réinvestira notre demande ses moyens sur
la régénération ferreviaère et ensuite
il faudra définir notamment le cadre
d'un contrat de performance revu une
trajectoire pluriannuelle visible et
augmentée j'insiste aussi sur les trains
d'équilibre du territoire les trains du
quotidien c'est un effort important qui
est porté dans ce budget plus 3
milliards d'euros pour financer ces
trains d'équilibre avec notamment des
réinvestissements pluri-annuels
extrêmement importants auquels vous le
savez je suis très attaché sur des
lignes qui ont été trop longtemps
négligées je pense en fait à
l'intégralité de nos lignes Intercité
mais à certains certaines qui sont
emblématiques à bien des égards la ligne
dite polte Paris orléant limoge Toulouse
la ligne Paris ClermontFerrand ou par
exemple la ligne bordeau Marseille dont
nous don nous rachetons aussi
l'intégralité des rames en même temps
que nous faisons sur la plupart de ces
lignes d'importants travaux de
modernisation ou de régénération du
réseau ferroviaire le frais de
ferroviaire est aussi au cœur de ses
priorités je reviendrai sur votre
question plus précise monsieur le
Président mais avec des efforts
importants pour nos infrastructures j'ai
annoncé le 2 3 mA il se retrouve en
partie dans ce PLF 4 milliards d'euros
d'investissement sur 10 ans pour nos
infrastructures de frites ferroviaire
car l'aide à l'explloitation est très
importante mais on a parfois trop
négligé l'infrastructure en matière de
fret qui est la clé de l'augmentation de
sa part modale conformément une
stratégie de doublement de la part du
fret ferroviaire dans le total du fret
d'ici la fin de la décennie j'insiste
sur les services express régionaux
métropolitain qui coche si je puis le
dire ainsi ces deux cases des transports
du quotidien et de la décarbonation je
serai bref car nous en avons nous en
avons longuement parlé et je vous en
remercie pour votre soutien large dans
l'hémicycle il y a quelques jours mais
sur le plan budgétaire je le redis ce
sont presque 800 millions d'euros qui
sont prévus dans la génération de CPR
qui est en cours de discussion qui est
une première étape pour des études et
des premiers travaux qui sera évidemment
complété sererme par sererme puisqu'ils
seront définis avec un plan de
financement avec un plan
d'investissement collectivement un
premier effort significatif de l'État
que nous compléterons donc dans dans les
années qui viennent schéma par schéma et
puis j'insiste sur les questions de
qualité de service bien sûr il faut le
choc d'offre bien sûr pour cela il faut
investir dans notre réseau dans nos
trains du quotidien dans ces nouveaux
services express régionaux et
métropolitains mais aussi dans des
outils j'entends des polémique ces
derniers jours sur le fait que le PLF
cacherait ou ne contiendrait pas des
crédits destinés au passerail ou au
titre unique il y a dans ce projet de VO
de finance suffisamment de crédit sur le
ferroviaire pour qu'évidemment ces
actions amorcer ou développer le plus
vite possible soit financé et il est
clair que sur le titre unique comme sur
le passerail l'état mobilisera des
crédits dès 2024 puisque il faudra avoir
cette discussion avec les régions et je
le souhaite commencer à faire
fonctionner notamment ce passerail dès
l'année 2024 en même temps que dès le
début de l'année prochaine nous
expérimenterons avec plusieurs
collectivités volontaires le titre
unique que j'ai souhaité lancé au mois
de février dernier pour revenir à
plusieurs de vos question monsieur le
Président et pardonnez-moi si je ne suis
pas plus détaillé sur le PLF mais je
pense que nous y reviendrons dans notre
échange notamment sur les questions des
rapporteurs mais vous m'avez posé
plusieurs questions cruciales la loi de
programmation ou la visibilité
pluriannuelle de notre effort en matière
de transport c'est une obligation et
c'est une nécessité politique au-delà de
ce que prévoit la Lom pour dire à nos
concitoyens aux collectivités au
Parlement ce qui'est notre fort dans la
durée c'est le sens des travaux du
Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures auquel le Sénat a était
directement associé la première ministre
a indiqué à la fin du mois de février
dernier sur remise de ce rapport que
c'était le scénario de planification
écologique qui nous servait de référence
je donne un ordre de grandeur puisque il
y a différentes façons de de compter les
projets mais ce scénario de
planification écologique et c'est très
clair c'est entre 25 et 30 milliards
d'euros d'investissement pour nos
transports entre cette année et la fin
de la législature en 2027 telle est
notre référence comment cette référence
doit se traduire se matérialiser dans un
document stratégique ou dans une loi qui
serait soumise et je l'espère voter au
Parlement vous savez monsieur le
Président que ma préférence va à une loi
de programmation je suis en train de
consulter les groupes politiques du
Sénat et de l'Assemblée nationale pour
examiner si dans notre calendrier
parlementaire contreint vous le savez il
y aurait une voix de passage pour le
dire ainsi majorit et parlementaire qui
permettrait de faire aboutir un tel
texte en tout cas il y aura dans les
prochaines semaines et je m'engage à
évidemment revenir vous en donner les
détails une visibilité pluri-annuelle
est consolidéein avec le même périmètre
que ces 13 et demi milliard d'euros que
j'évoque maintenant pour les années qui
viennent avec comme référence j'y
insiste ce scénario de planification
écologique du coi donc ce travail de
préparation de la trajectoire
plurannuelle a déjà été largement fait
par le COI et confirmé par la première
ministre dans la présentation de son
plan d'avenir pour les transports au
mois de février alors pour investir il
faut des financement ce sont des crédits
budgétaires importants qui sont
mobilisés j'ai évoqué cet effort
budgétaire de 13 et demi milliard
d'euros pour l'année prochaine mais dans
la durée pour augmenter nos
investissements puisque tel est l'enjeu
notamment sur la régénération du réseau
sur les trains d'équilibre du territoire
ou sur d'autres priorités notamment
ferroviaires et pour la décarbonation en
général nous assumons qu'il y a une
contribution supplémentaire qui est
demandé à certains acteurs du secteur
c'est cette fameuse taxe sur les
concessions l'article 15 que vous avez
évoqué qui porte sur les grandes
concessions qui concrètement aboutira à
faire contribuer pour investir en
décarbonation le secteur autoroutier le
secteur aéroportuaire pour un montant
estimé environ à 600 millions d'euros
par an c'est important puisque ça
représente sur la période entre cette
année et 2027 à peu près 2 milliards et
demi d'euros si le par Parlement vote
bien cette taxe et c'est donc environ si
je prends l'ordre de grandeur du
scénario de planification écologique 10
% des crédits nécessairire à ce scénario
qui seront ainsi mobilisés et financés
par une contribution spécifique du
secteur ou des secteurs affecter et
j'insiste sur ce point à l'Agence de
financement des infrastructures de
transport à la fite pour justement bien
démontrer
et organiser juridiquement une
affectation de ces sommes importantes à
à la décarbonation et à notre
investissement en matière de transport
pas seulement dans le ferroviaire
principalement dans le ferroviaire mais
pour la décarbonation de manière
général cette taxe a fait naître un
certain nombre de questions voire
d'inquiétude je leurais dit
singulièrement pour le secteur
autoroutier la question des péages est
organisée par les contrats et si cette
taxe est présentée par le Gouvernement
au Parlement c'est parce que nous
estimons même si les acteurs
autoroutiers peuvent ici même vous dire
leur interprétation contraire mais c'est
parce que nous estimons que cette taxe
est parfaitement conforme au contrat et
donc de la même façon la formule
d'évolution des péages est fixée par le
contrat et d'ailleurs entériné par des
arrêtés de l'état du gouvernement chaque
année et donc pour être très clair il
n'y a pas de possibilité d'augmenter les
péages au titre de cette
taxe il y aura ensuite probablement
puisque
les assujettil l'ont évoqué certains
d'entre eux en tout cas une procédure un
recours une procédure contentieuse nous
sommes un état de droit c'est le droit
de ceux qui ont un intérêt à agir comme
on dit mais je crois pouvoir dire avec
confiance avec une affirmation claire
que nous avons pris toutes les
précautions juridiques pour que la taxe
qui vous est proposée soit robuste
conforme au contrat évidemment
souverainement voté par la
représentation nationale quoi qu'en
pense les uns ou les autres et que la
formule d'indexation des contrats n'est
pas changée par cette taxe donc c'est
très important de le dire et de le
redire il y a des règles des évolution
des péages mais la taxe qui est proposée
aujourd'hui au Sénat ne remet en rien en
cause cette formule d'évolution des
tarifs des
péages je viens sur la question plus
prospective et plus stratégique sans
doute de la fin des contrats de
concession vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
le Président les concessions dites
historiques arrivent à échéance
rapidement 2031 j'ai évoqué plusieurs
fois publiquement et avec vous devant
vous le fait que si c'est sans doute pas
dans cette législature qu'il faudra
prendre une décision sur l'avenir des
concessions en revanche je crois que
notre responsabilité ma responsabilité
je le conçois ainsi et de préparer de la
manière la plus approfondie la plus
sereine possible aussi dans un débat qui
est parfois polémique les options pour
l'avenir de nos concessions
autoroutières et c'est dans ce sens que
j'ai évoqué devant l'Assemblée nationale
et je le redit devant le Sénat une
commission la plus ouverte possible qui
pendant plusieurs mois je le
souhaiterais ainsi avec des membres de
la représentation nationale avec des
organisations nongouvernementales avec
des économistes avec évidemment des
sociétés concernées puissent regarder
les options juridiques politiques et
stratégiques qui s'ouvr à nous qui
s'offre à nous pour l'après 2031 et je
pense que ce travail est important qu'il
faut le conduire maintenant pour
justement échapper à l'urgence de la
décision et préparer celle que sans
doute mes successeurs auront à prendre
euh je pense que c'est faire uvre utile
que de faire ce travail à ciel ouvert et
j'aurais souhaité qu'on puisse lancer
cette commission dès la rentrée dès
l'automne ça prend un peu plus de temps
et je ne voulais pas que ça soit percuté
par le débat actuel du projet de lo de
finance mais il faut que dans les
prochaines semaines je vous donnerai
toutes les précisions nécessaire en vous
associant évidemment nous puissions
entamer ce travail de réflexion ce
travail prospectif sur toutes les
options sans tabou pour l'avenir de nos
concessions autoroutières je l'ai
toujours dit toujours assumé je pense
que le modèle concessif a de nombreux
avantages notamment celui de nous donner
des perspectives de long terme mais ces
paramètres peuvent être discutés et
peuvent évidemment évoluer vous avez
évoqué monsieur le Président les travaux
du régulateur de l'Autorité de
régulation des transports qui préconise
par exemple d'avoir des contrats de
durée plus courtes c'est une des pistes
mais je ne veux pas préjuger puisque je
pense que ce travail doit précisément
être fait sur les concessions
elles-mêmes sur les paramètres des
concessions sur les périmètres des
concessions dans le cadre de cette
commission de travail d'investigation
euh au sens le plus profond du terme pas
au sens d'une enquête euh pour les
semaines et les mois qui viennent et
préparer ensuite les décisions
politiques qui devront être prises sans
doute après 2027 sur le fret
SNCF une précision puisque c'est un
sujet
important vous le savez j'ai l'occasion
de le dire la Commission européenne a
ouvert une procédure le 18 janvier
dernier je regrette l'ouverture de cette
procédure la France pense et nous
pensons toujours que les motifs ne le
justifient pas mais c'est ainsi nous
sommes là aussi dans un état de droit et
en l'occurrence il y a une compétence
qui relève de la Commission européenne
sur la question des aides d'État
supposées et face à cette procédure je
l'ai aussi assumé très clairement il y a
deux options pour dire les choses très
simplement la première qui consiste à ne
pas se préoccuper de la procédure
finalement ou à se battre pied à pied si
je puis dire le plus longtemps
possible avec un degré de coopération
variable on peut monter sur les
barricades ou discuter de manière
dilatoire avec la Commission européenne
tout ça peut prendre de longs mois c'est
vrai et sans doute dépasser le mandat
d'un ministre des Transports mais ça se
finit en général assez mal parce que
s'il faut rembourser ce qui est demandé
aujourd'hui par la Commission européenne
c'est 5,3 milliards d'euros qui sont en
jeu et même si ça n'était pas la
totalité de cette somme mais une partie
ou une grande partie de cette somme
qu'il faudrait rembourser car si la
commission une procédure c'est qu'il y a
quelques soupçons
étayés je crois que je suis même sûr que
l'entreprise notre opérateur public de
fret ferroviaire ne s'en remettrait pas
et ces agents les premiers et donc il y
a une autre option vous aurez compris
qu'elle a ma préférence c'est que c'est
celle que le gouvernement a retenu qui
est difficile qui n'est pas agréable qui
consiste à avoir une option rapide
d'accord avec les autorités européennes
pour garantir la pérenité d'un opérateur
de frait ferroviair avec des lignes
rouges et garanties qui sont aujourd'hui
sécurisé le maintien de 90 % des emplois
et évidemment de la totalité pour les
agents
concernés des emplois au sein du groupe
public ferroviaire SNCF personne n'est
au chômage évidemment mais 90 % des
emplois au sein de la nouvelle structure
de Fra ferroviaire deuxièmement qu'il y
ait un opérateur public qui puisse
continuer à opérer sur une partie du
périmètre actuel et troisièmement qu'il
n'y ait pas de report modal inversé
comme l'on dit d'où le plan de
réinvestissement massif dans le fret pas
seulement sur les aides d'exploitation
qui sont augmenté et pérénisé mais aussi
et surtout sur nos infrastructures de
frêes ferrovia avec un plan qui consiste
à rénover nos grandes gares de frêes
ferroviaires vous les connaissez parfois
dans vos départements je pense à la gare
de Miramas dans le sud dans les
bouchurones je pense à l'est à la gare
de voipi qui est la plus grande gare de
triage de France sous investissement
massif nous allons mettre les 80
millions d'euros nécessaires à ce
réinvestissement je ne serai pas plus
long
mais vous l'aurez compris je crois dur
comme faire au frais de ferroviaire je
pense qu'il faut surmonter cet épisode
difficile en assumant nos responsabilité
voilà ce que je crois être le plus
protecteur pour les agents pour le frais
de ferroviaire et pour l'écologie et
investir dans ce mode de transport
auquel nous croyons tous et auquel je
crois très profondément voilà pour
essayer de répondre monsieur le
Président à l'essentiel des questions
que vous avez soulevé à ce stade et je
suis évidemment à votre disposition pour
la suite merci monsieur le ministre je
va donner la parole la Philippe tabarou
oui monsieur le le président monsieur le
ministre j'ai l'instar de mes de mes
collègues de très nombreuses questions à
vous à vous poser mais je vais tâcher de
concentrer mon intervention sur les
dispositions et crédits du projet de loi
de finances pour 2024 consacré au
transport ferroviaire fluvial et
maritime tout d'abord nous pouvons nous
féliciter qu'à la fois nos multiples
alertes en commission le rapport du
Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures et c'est serv en fin
d'électrochoc le 24 février 2023 la
première ministre a annoncé le plan à
venir pour les transports avec 100
milliards d'investissements d'ici 2040
bien que de nombreuses cas sont encore
manquantes notamment les Pineux partag
du financement avec les cofinanceurs
cette perspective de long terme est à
saluer un horizon inédit pour certains
une communication de plus pour d'autres
mais pour moi c'est surtout la force de
cette ambition que je souhaite vérifier
dès aujourd'hui vous défendez un effort
sans précédent pour
2024 nous voyons bien plus une
progression de petit pas les enjeux vous
les connaissez parfaitement au carrefour
de la décarbonation la hausse du prix
des carburants le nécessaire report
modal l'accessibilité aux zones peu
Danes ou encore la décongestion des des
métropoles le secteur doit progresser
bien plus vite bien plus fort s'agissant
de transport ferroviaire je souhaiterais
vous interroger monsieur le ministre sur
la déclinaison concrète du plan àenir
pour les transports et de cette nouvelle
donne ferroviaire annoncé par la
première ministre plus de 8 mois plus
tard où en sommes-nous certes nous
observons dans le projet de loi de
finance une augmentation des crédits
consacrés au transport ferroviaire et je
m'en réjouis vous l'avez rappelé pour
autant les moyens déployés ne sont pas
encore à la hauteur des objectifs nous
l'avons vu très récemment avec la PPL
sur les CERMES dont j'ai été le
rapporteur ici au Sénat et qui forcer de
le constater ne prévoit aucunement les
modalités de financement de ces projets
c'est me diriez-vous me direz-vous et
vous l'avez dit plusieurs fois pendant
nos discussions lundi dernier près de
800 millions d'euros de crédit devrait
être partagé pour les études de
préalable dans le cadre des CP mais nous
ne savons rien de l'engagement de l'État
pour financer les travaux et ce constat
je pourrais le décliner à bien d'autres
égards pour ne prendre qu'un exemple
nous n'avons toujours pas de visibilité
ni de trajectoire sur le financement
précis pour la modernisation du réseau
et nous sommes particulièrement en
retard comme vous le savez si bien sur
le déploiement de le rTMS et la commande
centralisée du réseau comme vous le
savez également monsieur le ministre le
transport ferroviaire est un secteur de
temps long pour conserver nos filières
industriellees d'excellence nous mais
aussi permettre aux transporteurs et aux
gestionnaires d'infrastructures
d'assurer leur mission de dans de bonnes
conditions nous avons besoin de
visibilité aussi je rejoins bien sûr le
président longot comme souvent à quand
une nouvelle loi de programmation pour
les les infrransports ou à minima une
ventilation des dépenses des des 100
milliards annoncés par la première
ministre à quand une révision du contrat
de performance entre SNCS réseau et
l'État vous venez de de l'évoquer
euh un contrat qui je le répète une
nouvelle fois fait l'unanimité contre
lui par ailleurs pourriez-vous monsieur
le ministre nous faire un petit point
sur l'avancée du chantier liyon sur un
qui est un sujet de préoccupation
majeure dans cette commission sur le
transport fluvial je souhaiterais
aborder deux points au départ finalement
je vais aborder qu'un point la révision
du contrat d'objectif et de performance
de VNF conclu en avril 2021 qui a permis
de fixer un cap au développement du
transport fluvial pour la période 2029
en application de la Lom ce document
doit être révisé en 23 pour la première
fois où en sont les travaux pour
actualiser ce document et sur quels
aspects va porter c'est la révision dans
ce casadre prévoyez-vous de revoir à la
hausse la trajectoire d'investissement
de VNF en faveur du réseau fluvial qui
s'établit actuellement à 3 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2030 pour tenir compte du
plan àenir pour les transports et des
nouvelles recettes qui seront dégagées
grâce à la tax sur les infrastructures
de transport longue distance dont vous
avez parlé enfin s'agissant du transport
maritime et des ports je souhaite
évoquer le règlement
européen adopté en septembre dernier sur
le déploiement des infrastructures pour
carburant alternatif ce texte fixe
notamment des objectifs ambitieux en
matière de déploiement d'infras de
recharge dans les ports maritimes pour
permettre l'alimentation électrique des
navires àquai il est par exemple prévu
que d'ici 2030 les ports appartenant au
réseau central
rtet qui sont les plus fréquentés soit
équipés pour fournir chaque année
l'alimentation électrique àquai pour au
moins 90 % des escales effectués par des
navires portecontainer de plus de 5000
tonnes
le projet de loi de finan 24 ne comporte
aucune mesure sur ce point si ce n'est
l'enveloppe de 175 millions d'euros
prévu par le plan de relance depuis 2021
et qui est désormais presque
intégralement consommé comment le
gouvernement envisage envisage-t-il de
d'accompagner financièrement les ports
maritimes de cette transition enfin
permettez-moi une ultime question
subsidiaire sans empiété sur les
compétences de l'excellent collègue de
mili euh allez-vous vous mobiliser au au
côté des élus pour contester la
suppression sans aucune concertation des
lignes régulières d'Air-France depuis
Nice vers Orly ces suppressions sont une
erreur une faute un non respect pour
l'attractivité de notre merveilleuse
Côte d'Azur nous ne pouvons l'accepter
monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le rapporteur je
vais donner la parole à l'excellent
collègue Stéphane dem merci monsieur le
Président pour cette
introduction monsieur le ministre après
avoir traversé les turbulences de la
crise sanitaire le transport aérien
entre aujourd'hui et enfin dans une
période un peu plus sereine selon la la
DGAC le trafic aérien devrait atteindre
en 2024 son niveau de 2019 contre 94 %
cette année le ciel n'est toutefois pas
complètement dégagé pour le secteur je
souhaiterais vous poser un certain
nombre de questions sur le projet de loi
de finance car le transport aérien est
en effet concerné par plusieurs mesures
fiscales examiner lors de la première
partie du PLF et j'ai six questions
précises à vous poser l'article 13 du du
PLF prévoit des mesures relatives à la
taxe incitative relative à l'utilisation
d'énergie renouvelable dans les
transports la fameuse tiwette l'objectif
cible
d'incorporation carburant aérien durable
passe de 1,5 % en 2024 à 2 % en 2025
autrement dit les compagnies aériennes
peront un montant proportionnel à
l'écard avec la cible si ell ne
l'atteignent pas pour le dire encore
autrement la pénalité sera équivalente
au motant du manque de carburant durable
lui-même coefficienté d'une une pénalité
de non respect des règles pourquoi faire
simple quand on peut faire compliqué
tout cela en intégrant le fait que sur
le plan fiscal le double compte
c'est-à-dire la multiplication par deux
des montants incorporés disparaît
dorenavant on ne prend en compte que la
réelle incorporation or aujourd'hui il
faut savoir que la plupart des
compagnies paient la taxe et n'incorpore
pas le pourcentage cible actuel qui
n'est que de 1 %. le président de la
République a dévoilé à l'occasion du
Salon du Bourget un plan qui me semble
encore un peu timide en faveur des
carburants aériens du durable ma
première question est la suivante
comment comptez-vous accompagner ces
fameux objectifs
d'incorporation vous n'allez pas être
surpris monsieur le ministre par ma
deuxième question qui concerne la taxe
sur l'exploitation d'infrastructure de
transport de longue distance c'est un
terme un petit peu long pour dire qu'on
souhaite taxer les gros aéroports que
sont Paris Marseille Nice et et Toulouse
les aéroports me semble être la victime
collatérale d'une collision malheureuse
entre la volonté gouvernementale de
taxer les concessions autoroutières et
l'analyse du Conseil d'État qui
considère qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
qu'un seul mouton noir dans le transport
alors on s'en prend à nouveau à
l'aérien pourtant lui-même vous le savez
victime d'une transition énergétique
particulièrement coûteuse cette taxe
devrait avoir un impact d'une centaine
de millions d'euros sur les aéroports du
groupe ADP qui seront ensuite
naturellement répercuté sur les
redevances payées par les compagnies
aériennes et en premier chef air fr
France comment comptez-vous monsieur le
ministre limiter les effets de
distorsion de concurrence de ce
dispositif au détriment d'Air France et
au profit des compagnies aériennes
lowcost étrangères présentes dans les
aéroports régionaux c'est ma deuxième
question par ailleurs des amendements
ont été adoptés sans prospérer par la
suite pour accroître les prélèvements
fiscaux sur l'aviation d'affaires par
nos collègues et homologue de la
commission du développement durable à
l'Assemblée nationale quelle est votre
position personnelle sur ces
propositions monsieur le ministre c'est
ma 3è question concernant les crédits
relatifs au transport aérien je me
réjouis de la stabilité des crédit
consacrés aux lignes d'aménagement du
territoire monsieur le ministre je tiens
à vous rappeler que la Commission bien
sûr exerce sur ces lignes essentielles
pour désenclaver certains territoires
une vigilance particulièrement renforcée
la Commission est également
particulièrement investie sur un sujet
central pour nos concitoyens la
limitation des nuisances sonores
aéroportuaires la taxe sur les nuisance
sonore aérienne la tnsa souffre d'un
rendement en berne depuis la crise
sanitaire or le niveau de nuisance ne
diminue pas vraiment que vous soyez
réveillé par deux ou trois avions ou par
CIN ou si vous êtes réveillé pour
attraper le retard prix non pas dans le
sommeil mais dans les travaux
d'isolation phonique des bâtiments un
abondement budgétaire conséquent est
nécessaire et a priori sauf erreur
j'allais dire sauf erreur souhaitable de
ma part il n'est pas prévu ai-je raté
une ligne budgétaire dans laall
ou est-ce un oubli de libérer ou non de
votre part c'était ma 4è question j'en
viiens maintenant à la situation de la
DGAC je tiens à saluer l'ambition
concernant la trajectoire de
désentêement et naturellement la
Commission veillera à ce qu'elle soit
bien tenue sans pour autant obérer les
nécessaires investissements de
modernisation néanmoins je m'inquiète du
risque de dérapage des dépenses du
personnel permettez-moi d'être directe
dans ma 5e question quel est le coût de
l'accord de trêv olympique négocié avec
le principal syndicat des contrôleurs
aériens et la DGAC en septembre dernier
ou pour le dire autrement et encore plus
directement quel est le coût de cette
paix
négociée enfin et pour conclure monsieur
le ministre permettez au sénateur de la
somme que je suis de vous poser une
dernière question sur le projet du
barreau roissi Picardi la fameuse ligne
ferroviaire de 6,5 km entre vemmard et
marley- Laville dans le valdoise
aujourd'hui le projet fait face à une
forte augmentation de son coût on évoque
la signature d'un accord européen pour
boucler le financement à la fin de
l'année 2026 pour boucler le budget d'un
projet qui est passé de 350 millions
d'euros en 2017 à 570 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui confirmez-vous cette
information c'était ma 6e et ma dernière
question monsieur le ministre merci pour
les questions concernant les territoires
proprement dit vous pourrez les poser
mais je suis pas sûr que le ministre
pourra répondre à tout donc je vais avec
lui il vous lu répondra aussi par par
courrier la parole est au rapporteur
Hervé gilet merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je souhaite pour ma part vous
interroger sur quatre points donc
relatif au PLF et consacré au transport
routier et plus particulièrement aussi à
l'actualité de de ce secteur le premier
concerne les zones à faible émission de
mobilité l'article 26 du PLF pour 2024
prévoit la rétrocession du produit des
des amendes prononcé en zfem aux
collectivités territoriales et donc à ce
sujet où en est le développement de
l'outil de lecture automatisée des
plaques d'immatriculation Lapi dont le
déploiement accuse déjà plusieurs années
de retard la nouvelle échéance du 2e
semestre 2024 sera-t-elle respectée
s'agissant de l'acquisition du
dispositif sera-t-elle entièrement à
charge des collectivités territoriales
ou un soutien financier est-il à l'étude
d'autre part madame barbara pomilet a
rendu il y a quelques jours son rapport
sur l'acceptabilité des zones à faible
mission qui recommande notamment de les
inscrire dans une politique globale de
mobilité afin de développer les
alternatives à l'usage individuel de la
voiture dans cet objectif il me semble
indispensable de renforcer
l'interopérabilité des titres de
transport la billeéthique peut en effet
être un levier efficace pour encourager
cette intermodalité et tendre vers des
mobilités sans couture à l'échelle des
bassins de vie identifiez-vous des
pistes pour encourager le développement
de système billétiqu interopérable au
niveau local intégrant l'ensemble des
services de transport alternatifs à
l'autosolisme et en en articulant les
offres de transport relevant des
différentes autorités organisatrices de
la
mobilité le deuxième point concerne les
aides à l'acquisition de véhicules
propres pour les usagers et plus
particulièrement le leasing social qui
doit permettre aux ménages les plus
modestes de louer un véhicule électrique
pour 100 € par mois les documents
budgétaires indiquent que ce dispositif
annoncé depuis le printemps 2022 par le
gouvernement entrera en vigueur au
premier janvier 2024 or en dépit de
l'iminence de cette échéance les
paramètres et modalités de mise en œuvre
du dispositif n'ont toujours pas été
clarifiés pouvez-vous nous indiquer
quelles seront les règles d'éligibilité
au leasing social et notamment si des
critères particuliers seront mis en
place pour tenir compte de la proximité
d'une zfeu en complément où en est-on de
la mise en œuvre de l'expérimentation
sur le prêt à taux zéro sur
l'acquisition de véhicules popolement
pour les personnes travaillants au
résidents et des feux introduits dans la
loi climat et résilience à l'initiative
de notre commission j'en viens à présent
à quelques questions relatives aux
infrastructures de transport routier
alors 3è point je souhaitis à mon tour
vous interroger sur l'article 15 du
projet de loi de finance pour 2024 qui
porte création d'une taxe sur
l'exploitation des infrastructure de
transport longue distance il est prévu
d'affecter le produit de cette taxe qui
pourrait représenter 600 millions
d'euros pour la première année à la fit
ce dont on peut à priori que se réjouir
tant la fite constitue un levier de
report modal au bénéfice des modes
massifiés ce C tant la mise en œuvre de
cette nouvelle taxe inspire plusieurs
questions d'une part comment d'après
vous peut-on concrètement garantir que
cette taxe ne sera pas répercutée sur
les usagers des des autoroutes qui ont
déjà subi d'importantes augmentation de
péage ces dernières années et dans un
contexte vous le savez très contraint
d'autre part je souhaiterais évoquer
avec vous les propos de plusieurs
dirigeants des sociétés concessionnaires
qui ont indiqué plusitement leur
intention d'aller au contentieux au cas
de la mise en place de cette taxe ces
derniers considèrent qu'elle n'est pas
conforme à la clause de neutralisation
fiscal prévu par les contrats de
concession ces déclarations sont de
nature à nous inquiéter quand même sur
la solidité juridque même si vous avez
apporté déjà des premiers éléments de
réponse sur ce sujet au-delà de ces
questions relatives à la contribution du
secteur autoroutier au financement du
système de transport je souhaiterais
vous interroger sur le financement des
mobilités en zone pedance nous nous
réjouissons de la création de l'article
27 bis qui porte relèvement du taux
plafond du versement mobilité de 0,25
points à Paris et dans les trois
départements de la petite couronne pour
autant cela ne règle pas la question
plus profonde du financement des
mobilités dans les zones les moins dans
qui ne bénéfici pas d'une base fiscale
suffisante pour ne serait-ce que lever
le versement mobilité et qui sont plus
que les zones urbaines des zones dans
lesquelles la dépendance à l'automobile
est la plus forte comment voyez-vous les
choses donc monsieur le ministre comment
soutenir ces territoires dans leur
marche vers des transports moins
carbonés enfin pour finir me faisant le
relais de mon collègue Monsieur Olivier
Jacquin la transition écologique et le
déploiement des afeu nécessite
d'augmenter considérablement les moyens
financiers dédiés au transport collectif
le garde demande une concertation
nationale sur le versement mobilité
êtes-vous prêt à vous y engager sans
tabou afin de revoir l'ensemble des
paramètres je pense ici au seuil
d'assugestissement la liberté de fixer
les plafonds localement selon les
besoins et les investissements aux
solutions alternatives quand les
territoires sont dépourvus de base
adéquate comme je viens de l'évoquer
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
Monsieur le minist je vous propose de
répondre à nos trois rapporteurs et puis
après je vais donner la parole à mes
autres collègues signale que le ministre
doit partir vers 17h30 et que nous avons
encore 12
interventions je ser que la mienne soit
donc efficace monsieur le Président euh
monsieur le sénateur Tabarot sur le plan
d'inest le plan d'avenir pour les
transports en effet présenté par la
première ministre le 24 février ça
renvoie la question de du support que
nous voulons avoir pour donner la plus
grande visibilité vous aurez compris mon
intérêt je crois qu'il est partagé même
s'il peut y avoir ensuite sur le contenu
différentes approches pour une loi de
programmation ça n'est pas une annonce
c'est une hypothèse de travail sur
laquelle encore une fois je termine la
concertation des différents groupes
politiques de l'Assemblée nationale et
du Sénat mais j'insiste d'abord le
scénario de planification écologique
servira quoi qu'il arrive de référence
au gouvernement vous connaissez bien ce
scénario puisqu'il prévoit c'est le
deuxème scénario du coi cette somme
importante que j'ai évoqué entre 25 et
30 millions d'euros en crédit de
paiement d'investissement sur la période
2020 23 2027 et c'est bien dans ce cadre
là et sur cette trajectoire là que se
fonde le projet de lo de finance pour
2024 même si évidemment par nature il ne
donne pas la trajectoire pluriannuelle
en lui-même j'insiste aussi sur le fait
que plusieurs briques de ce mur non pas
le mur d'investissement auquel on se
confronte mais du mur que nous
construisons pour investir davantage
justement plusieurs éléments ont été
enclenchés depuis le mois de février
pluriannuel et important je pense à la
nouvelle génération de CP j'ai iste le
montant annuel tel qu'il ressort des
mandats que j'ai adressé avec le Premier
ministre au préfet pour la part de
l'État c'est 50 % de plus que dans la
génération précédente la négociation est
en cours peut-être que ça sera encore un
peu davantage mais c'est un effort
d'investissement qui traduit cette
priorité d'investissement général
supérieur renforcé et notamment pour le
ferroviaire et transport collectif c'est
2/ers même 70 % pour être précis des
mandats qui ont été confiés au préfets
de région partout en France nous avons
lancé avec le cadre jridque que voté ici
même il y a quelques jours la question
est le chantier des CERMES avec encore
une fois une première étape de
financement qui sont qui est intégré
dans les CPR et l'autre qui ne peut pas
encore être défini non pas parce que je
chercherai à la cacher l'occulter
l'éviter mais parce qu'elle sera le
résultat des projets que soumettront les
collectivités locales certains sont très
avancés je pense au projet du lois
certains le sont moins en terme
d'investissement et de financement mais
une fois la loi votée je l'espère le
plus rapidement possible il y aura un
délai je l'indiquerai publiquement donné
de quelques mois aux collectivités
régions et métropoes principalement pour
soumettre leur projets valider si la loi
reste en l'état par le ministre chargé
des transports et ensuite le financement
se fait sans doute d'abord des études
puis des premiers travaux les crédits
sont mobilisables d'abord dans les CPR
et ensuite on aura euh je sais pas quel
modalité ça prendra vous avez évoqué des
conférences de financement j'y suis
ouvert euh de manière globale et de
manière spécifique une étape de
négociation financière sur la
régénération du réseau ferroviaire on
s'est fixé un objectif qui est très
clair monter de 3 milliards d'euros à
4,5 milliards d'euros annuels entre
maintenant cette année 2023 et 2027 une
première marche qui correspond à cette
trajectoire est franchie avec le PLF
2024 même si cet effort dans un premier
temps sera une sorte de non dividende
perçue par l'État depuis la SNCF et
d'investissement interne au groupe SNCF
pour la suite je ne sais pas s'il fait
l'unanimité contre lui je trouve qu'il a
le mérite de renforcer certains moyens
et d'exister sur 10 ans le contrat de
performance devra être actualisé pour
traduire c'est très clair ce montant de
régénération et de modernisation
supplémentaire dans notre réseau
ferroviaire c'est aussi un outil
pluriannuel j'ai conscience que le
secteur des transports est en complexe
par la diversité des outils budgétaires
et ça c'est heureux la décentralisation
des compétences qui fait qu'il y a
toujours plusieurs acteurs sur un sujet
les outils sont nombreux CP service
express régionaux métropolitain contrat
de performance pour le réseau mais mis
bout à bout il tracent cette ambition et
traduisent concrètement cette ambition
du plan d'avenir pour les transports et
je souhaite comme vous qu'on puisse
donner cette image globale le plus vite
possible
sur le projet du lyonurin je serai
rapide mais l'engagement est clair je
crois qu'il a été clairement affirmé
aussi clairement affirmé pour la
première fois sur le financement des
accès par l'État j'ai engagé réengagé
une discussion constructive je dois le
dire avec le président vquier sur le
financement notamment des études des
accès au lyonturin j'espère que cette
discussion entre l'État et la région
mais il faut d'autres acteurs aussi mais
c'est principalement l'État et la région
qui sont concernés aboutira d'ici la fin
deannée 20 23 on retient le scénario du
grand gabarit comme on le sait ça
c'était la première étape maintenant il
faut le financer l'État est prêt à
mettre jusqu'à 3 milliards d'euros je
l'ai dit la région est prête à financer
notamment la la phase d'étude en
cofinancement avec nous donc je pourrais
je pense je l'espère vivement vous
donner le détail de ces financements
dans les prochaines semaines sur VNF
très important deux
choses nous avons décidé avec Christophe
Béchu c'était d'ailleurs une des
demandes du Sénat l'an dernier que ce
qu'on appelle publiquement le schéma
d'emploi soit il a zéro cette année donc
c'est en fait un gain d'emploi puisque
la modernisation et l'automatisation
dégage des effectifs normalement VNF
devait en quelque sorte les rendre et
être compensé pour absorber cette
transition par des contrats temporaires
je vais faire simple nous avons décidé
que l'automatisation dégager des emplois
au sein de VNF que ne l'État que l'État
pardon ne lui demande pas de rendre
cette année donc zéro effort sur les
emplois à VNF c'est un geste important
qui montre la priorité que nous donnons
au fluvial sur le COP lui-même qui est
un effort d'investissement important
d'environ 1 milliard d'euros oui il faut
le réviser c'est d'ailleurs prévu ainsi
par le contrat lui-même tous les 3 ans
cette révision est engagé elle doit
aboutir d'ici la fin d'année et bien sûr
pour faire clair nous allons reéhausser
la trajectoire conformément aux travaux
du coi tout en continuant de moderniser
l'établissement public je veux rendre
hommage en particulier à son directeur
général don vous savez que puisqu'il a
justement été remarquable le président
de la République a décidé de proposer au
Sénat comme à l'Assemblée nationale sa
nomination à une autre éminente de
fonction c'était je crois attendu et je
pense que c'est un grand serviteur de
l'État qui en a les qualités sur les
ports maritimes l'électrification en
particulier c'est essentiel une
obligation européenne qui a été fixée à
2030 vous l'avez dit pour tous les ports
du réseau trans-européen on a en effet
mobilisé 175 millions d'euros dans le
cadre du plan de relance 115 millions
d'euros dans les CPR en cours de
négociation donc peut-être un peu plus
en fonction de la négociation mais enfin
c'est un montant quasiment équivalent
donc un important pour continuer cet
effort d'investissement dans
électrification en complément de ce que
feront les collectivités locales pardon
en incluant ce que feront les
collectivité local et parfois sont
mobilisés d'autres crédits je pense par
exemple au port de marseille-fosse ou le
fond vert et utilisé pour augmenter
l'effort de l'État en complément de ce
que fait en particulier la région et la
ville et puis nous serons même sans
doute en avance je pense notamment à
marseillefosse qui est un des ports les
plus avancés en France sur
l'électrification à quai nous serons je
le crois en avant sur les obligations
européennes sans doute dès 2027 c'est ce
qu'a évoqué le présent de la République
dans sa dernière vite à Marseille pour
le port de Marseille et sans doute pour
les autres grands ports français
notamment Le Havre
ouinerque sur les lignes
aérienne c'est comme sur les autoroutes
euh quand on se fait accuser de toute
part c'est sans doute que on est dans le
juste milieu euh donc on nous reproche
de fermer des liges on nous reproche de
ne pas enfermer euh c'est pas une
décision de l'État Air France est une
entreprise dont l'état est actionnaire
mais pas actionnaire majoritaire je vais
être très direct avec vous je regrette
la méthode qui a été trop rapide et qui
aurait mérité une discussion approfondie
avec les élus concernés de la Côte
d'Azur ou d'ailleurs puisque la ville de
Toulouse est concernée par exemple euh
vous l'avez cité implicitement à la fois
la liaison pour Marseille et pour Nice
euh mais c'est un une étape de travail
car France a annoncé j'insiste sur ce
point j'ai demandé et la dire direction
d'Air France est très engagé estce qu'il
y a une discussion avec les élus locaux
d'ailleurs Renaud Muselier Caro delgat
plusieurs autres Christian estrosil
l'ont indiqué pour que la desserte
puisque c'est ça qui compte le plus soit
assurée au bon niveau y compris au-delà
de 2026 qui est l'horizon du plan
annoncé par Air France via notamment
Transavia donc c'est une discussion qui
commence ce n'est pas la fin de
l'histoire et l'entreprise est attachée
les élu plus encore et c'est légitime à
la qualité d'une desserte économiquement
indispensable touristiquement
indispensable vers Paris je suivrai ces
travaux de très près vous avez sans
doute vu les communiqués récents
notamment du président Muselier qui
montre que ce travail de concertation il
aura peut-être d être fait différemment
se traduit aujourd'hui par des réunions
dans les prochains jours
euh mon le sénateur de je vais essayer
d'être rapide sur vos six questions mais
complet sur les carburants durables
priorité essentiell je l'ai dit moi-même
depuis de long mois parce que c'est une
filière qui va devenir stratégique et on
ne peut pas là aussi j'essaie d'être
cohérent demander des efforts à
l'aviation si on ne soutient pas y
compris par les aides publiques je
l'assume sa stratégie de décarbonation
ce sont les aides du Corac 300 millions
par an et ce sont les 200 millions
d'euros annoncé par le présent de la
République au Bourget pour financer des
sites et des investissements sur des
sites de carburant durabl nous devrons
pour être très clair
avec sur votre question relative à la
tirwererte mettre en adéquation le
système européen le système national
nous avons été pionniers tant mieux pour
obliger à des incorporations à des des
des des des mandats pardon d' cororation
dans les avions de ces carburant durbles
désormais il y a une règle européenne
qui va plus loin en durée et en ambition
et donc il faudra évidemment que on
nimpose pas à nos compagnies d'avoir
deux systèmes contradictoires ou deux
systèmes différents ce sera le système
européen qui va être retenu et c'est
aussi l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
nous devons et nous devrons adapter
encore l'année prochaine le système de
la tirewererte mais les compagnies le
savent je le dis très clairement les
aéroports le savent c'est le système
issu du texte dit fuel eu refuel eu
pardon qui sera appliqué et nous
n'aurons pas deux cadres juridique
différent il faudra donc adapter le
cadre national sur la taxe sur les
infrastructures et sa partie concernant
les aéroport c'est un débat légitime
savoir s'il y a des seuils ou pas il y a
des avantages et des inconvénients je
vais être tout à fait honnête si vous
avez des seuils trop bas pour les
infrastructures en général qu'elle soit
autoroutière routière ou aéroportuaire
vous mettez à contribution les aéroports
régionaux par exemple qui ont moins de
capacités
contributive et serait posé parfois
d'autres problèmes d'emploi
d'attractivité économique de desserte de
certains territoires aussi donc le choix
a été fait par le gouvernement de
proposer au Parlement effectivement une
taxe à sortie d'un seuil je souhaite
pour qu'on donne de la visibilité qu'on
touche pas ce seuil Parlement décidera
souverainement mais nous regarderons
l'effet qu'il a évidemment dans les
années qui
viennent donc je sais a France l'a dit
par exemple que ça peut bénéficier du
coup des facto à certaines compagnies
dit low cost qui opèent plutôt dans les
aéroports régionaux moins dans les
aéroports directement concernés par la
taxe mais nous serons vigilants à ces
effets de compétitivité relative je suis
un défenseur du pavillon français et
donc on regardera évidemment les effets
de la taxe mais pense que c'est
important aussi de prendre en compte le
fait que s'il y avait pas de seuil
beaucoup d'infrastructur et compris
d'ailleurs hors aéroport et autoroute
peut-être des ports et cetera seraiit
misise à contribution ce qui pose à mon
avis des difficultés bien plus grandes
et je me félicite d'ailleurs que au
total notamment grâce au soutien de
l'État la compétitivité d'Air France les
résultats le montrent récemment c'est
rétabli sur l'aviation d'affaires je
vais être très clair je l'ai dit
publiquement à l'Assemblée nationale
donc je ne vais pas tricher avec les
compte-rendus au mois d'avril je
souhaite qu'on puisse compléter la taxe
qui a été porté l'an dernier dans le PLF
la loi de finance sur les avions détenus
en propre par une taxe équivalente des
faits équivalents sur les avions qui
sont loués cela n'a pas été retenu dans
un débat écourté à l'Assemblée nationale
nous aurons sans doute l'occasion d'en
rediscuter mais je ne vais pas vous
cacher ma position puisque je l'ai
exprimé je crois le 6 avril à la
Assemblée nationale sur la tnsa autre
contribution très différente oui il y a
un sujet il faut remettre à plat cette
son mode defin ce financement parce que
nous aurons besoin de plus de continuer
nos financements pour renforcer la lutte
contre les nuisance aéroportuaire c'est
clair est-ce que il faut le faire
immédiatement est-ce queil faut ouvrir
un chantier que le Parlement d'ailleurs
pourrait conduire pour regarder comment
on fait vivre cette taxe dans la durée
j'y suis ouvert mais vous avez raison de
pointer du doigt le fait qu'on a
post covid aujourd'hui une difficulté de
délai de financement des travaux contre
les nuisances aéroportuaires sur
la l'accord dit de trève olympique dans
le secteur du contrôle aérien je vais
vous dire moi j'ai une grande fierté de
cet accord que je ne considère pas être
ni une rançon ni un raquette ni un
accord masqué d'abord les syndicats
eux-mêmes qui l'ont signé ont rendu
publique une partie de cet accord je
vais pas donner un chiffre aujourd'hui
parce que que il y a encore des
négociations sociales dans le secteur
mais je vais le dire notamment un des
syndicats majoritaires a été toujours
très responsable ces derniers mois je
veux saluer ce courage là et l'accord
qui est signé est un accord extrêmement
raisonnable et responsable qui permet de
tenir compte des effets d'évolution de
la rémunération de l'inflation et qui a
une négociation sociale comme dans tout
secteur cela ne me choque pas et de
prendre une responsabilité collective
pour que quand nous accueillerons les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
notamment la France ne donne pas l'image
d'un pays où ces aéroports seraient
bloqués je pense que personne ne peut le
comprendre et je préfère qu'on a négocié
de manière
anticipée plutôt que en quelque sorte
collectivement d'ux au mur à quelques
jours d'un grand événement international
je pense que les conditions n'auraient
pas été collectivement les mêmes donc
cet accord moi j'ai aucun problème à
tenir régulièrement au courant le Sénat
des discussions sociales qui sont en
cours mais il est important puissant
équilibré et je pense qu'on devrait s'en
réjouir je note que de la même façon en
responsabilité avec DUP courage le Sénat
l'a eu il y a quelques mois nous faisons
voter des propositions de loi vous votez
des propositions de loi qui réforment
aussi le contrôle aérien tout en
respectant le droit de grève c'était la
proposition de loi du sénateur capo
canelas qui va êre prochainement discuté
à l'Assemblée nationale donc regardons
l'image d'ensemble c'est un secteur qui
fait des efforts qui se modernise dont
les salariés les agents assurent cette
modernisation et dans lequel on assume
un dialogue social qui a longtemps pas
bien pas bien avancé et qui aujourd'hui
est de bonne qualité sur le projet
Roissy Picardi même si monsieur le
président m'a invité à être bref sur les
projets spécifiques j'insiste il est
très important je le redis il faut qu'on
trouve une solution de financement des
surcûts nous n'avons pas eu de
financement européen cette fois-ci mais
il faut qu'on trouve une solution de
financement indépendamment des j'espère
bonnes nouvelles qui arriveront de
financement européen ultérieurement
autrement dit nous sommes en train de
discuter j'ai mandaté à cet égard le
préfait de région pour trouver une
solution de financement collectif l'état
il prendra évidemment une part
importante du projet roiss Cardi dont il
est hors de question de ne pas assurer
le déploiement dans les temps prévus je
ne peux pas être plus clair
euh dernier point pardon pour répondre
enfin dernier point au pluriel pour vous
répondre monsieur le sénateur Gil sur
les lectures de plaques automatisées oui
avec Christophe Béchu nous avons fait si
je puis dire la vérité des prix et lancé
enfin le marché quand nous sommes
arrivés l'an dernier donc l'horizon 2024
demeure on tiendra au courant de son
déploiement sur l'interopérabilité des
titres de transport oui même trois fois
oui c'est l'expérimentation puis la
généralisation je l'espère du titre
unique que je porte depuis le mois de
février dernier et plusieurs
collectivités régions et métropoles sont
volontaires pour expérimenter dès l'an
prochain cette interopérabilité ce titre
unique de transport qu'il faudra ensuite
Reder et je l'espère généraliser dans
les 2 ans qui viennent sur le leasing
social il est porté enfin ces crédits
pardon sont portés par le programme 164
la ministre agespan runaché en est aussi
la
garante pour être très clair on prévoit
on donnera le détail des paramètres dans
les toutes prochaines semaines puisqueil
faut que la réservation soit ouverte
avant la fin de l'année pour que les
véhicules les premiers véhicule soit
disponible en 2024 je vais être très
clair sur certains points on a fait le
choix assumer que il y a un critère
environnemental pour le dire directement
ce sont plutôt des véhicules qui sont
produits à proximité France et Europe
qui seront éligibles au dispositif ce
qui fait aussi et c'est assumé pour les
raisons de souveraineté que nous
n'aurons pas un nombre qui se compat en
centaines de de véhicules dès la
première année ce sera plutôt en
dizaines de milliers et ce sera un petit
volume de véhicules la première année
parce que nous assumons que ce soit des
véhicules des constructeurs français
européens pour le dire rapidement je
pense que c'est mieux de le faire ainsi
personne ne comprendrait qu'on fasse
comme pour le bonus écologique une
subvention massive d'industrie très
lointaine et pas très
environnementale donc c'est un
dispositif qui montera en puissance
progressivement est-ce que du coup il
faut cibler territorialiser la première
année c'est une discussion que nous
avons et que nous n'avons pas encore
complètement tranché je suis ouvert même
favorable à ce que on assume
complètement qu'il a pas des centaines
de milliers de véhicules de la première
année le président de la République l'a
dit d'ailleurs à l'issue du conseil de
planification écologique plus plôt des
dizaines de milliers mais que on donne à
certains territoire peut-être un
avantage sur d'autres pour commencer à
entrer dans le dispositif le faire
fonctionner en 2024 et l'étendre
progressivement en 2025 26 et 27 en
tenant notre objectif de 100000
véhicules éligibles à ce dispositif
d'ici la fin de la législature
et il y aura je le dis aussi des
véhicules qui seront à moins de 100 €.
c'est important aussi il y aura des
véhicules qui seront disponibles à moins
de 100 € donc c'est un dispositif qui
sera très attractif la taxe je peux pas
le dire là plus clairement enfin si je
vais le dire encore plus clairement la
taxe sur les infrastructures n'augmente
pas les péages il y a des règles
relatives au péag séparément la taxe
n'augmente pas les péages et moi j'ai
une conception peut-être un peu vieux
jeux des choses on peut avoir des débats
sur les avis juridiques des uns ou des
autres on peut aller au contentieux
c'est un état de droit encore une fois
que le nôtre enfin c'est le gouvernement
qui prépare les propositions de taxe
ou les projets et c'est le Parlement qui
les vote pas les
assuétis conception peut-être un peu
classique mais je pense que c'est mieux
si on se dit les choses comme ça après
il peut y avoir des débats des opinions
personnel des auditions où chacun défend
sa position mais préfère qu'on le dise
comme ça sur les zones pedances vous
avez raison et le versement mobilité qui
est un autre débat n'y pourvoirz pas
compte tenu du potentiel fiscal et des
limites que vous avez évoqué mais
d'autres solutions exigent j'en cite une
parce qu'elle est importante c'est ce
que nous avons déployé pardon avec
Dominique fort ces dernières semaines
dans le cadre du Plan France ruralité 90
millions d'euros de crédit spécifiques
pour financer cofinancer soutenir en
ingénierie ou en déploiement des
solutions de mobilité rurale développé
par les intercommunalité ça peut être de
l'autopartage ça peut être un
déploiement de d'infrastructure type
borne électrique pour encourager des
communes ou des interco qui ont moins de
moyens à le faire
sur sur la question de Monsieur Jacquin
que vous relayez je l'oublie Paron c la
concertation nationaleéation
[Musique]
pardon la proposition du GART oui alors
moi j'y suis ouvert j'essaie là aussi de
pas tenir de double discours je suis
sollicité par l'Assemblée département de
France pour de grandes assises du
financement des mobilités pardon si
j'écorche le nom proposé par région de
France j'étais au congrès à Saint-Malo
pour à peu près le même exercice et puis
par le gar pour être clair oui il faut
se poser la question notamment dans le
cadre des ser mais pas que du
financement des mobilités ça n'est pas
que la question du versement mobilité ça
n'est pas qu'une question francilienne
vous avez raison c'est une vraie
question monsieur le sénateur Tabarot a
poussé avec le soutien de plusieurs
collègues d' majorité par définition
puceque ça a été voté une question de
conférence de financement je ne sais pas
ce qui sera retenu par la commission
mixte paritaire mais en tout cas qui a
ce travail sur le financement des CERMES
et des transports publics j'y suis
ouvert je préfère qu'on multiplie pas
les assises dans une enceinte ou dans
l'autre en touti que l'État assume cette
discussion avec les collec acité
globalement oui dans les prochains
mois
merci pour que tout le monde puisse
poser ses question comme il y a 12
interventions on pose la question
directement que ça dure sur une minute
pour que le ministre puisse répondre
parce que si vous posez la question vous
avez pas de réponse c'est ennuyeux je
donne la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous avez fait part
de votre engagement pour les transports
du quotidien avec la la part importante
pour le ferroviaire moi je voudrais vous
alerter sur Laan nécessité de de
préserver d'augmenter la desserte en TGV
pour pour le grand ouest et
particulièrement pour mon département de
la Mayenne en effet ce TGV est très
fréquenté les trains sont complets donc
est-ce que le
gouvernement va s'engager pour soutenir
une augmentation de de la dcerte du
Grand Ouest surtout dans un contexte où
on a des des dysfonctionnements avec les
TER alors là aussi la région des Pays de
la Loire va investir et annoncer la
commande de nouvell RAM une trentaine
est-ce que le gouvernement va va s
soutenir la région des Pays de l'aloire
dans cet investissement cette même
région qui a subi l'abandon du projet
Notre-Dame des land donc il y avait eu
le le contrat d'avenir signé il y a un
peu plus de de 4 ans qui aujourd'hui les
engagements n'ont pas été tenus
notamment concernant le réaménagement de
l'aéroport donc qu'en est-il de votre
engagement pour le Grand Ouest monsieur
le ministre et dernier point très
rapidement siégeant au Conseil national
de l'air la qualité de l'air dans les
transports Souter parisien est
importante la RATP s'est engagé sur le
sujet l'Europe est également mobilisé
pour améliorer et augmenter
les les ambitions en la matière donc qui
est l'accompagnement l'État est prêt à
apporter à la RATP d'une façon générale
sur le ses objectifs de qualité de l'air
dans les transports du quotidien merci
ministre
oui merci monsieur le Président sur la
desserte du grand ouest
oui il y a des progrès à faire notamment
je pense sur la desserte grande vitesse
où il y a une un problème de fiabilité
notamment depuis le début de l'année
2023 ça m'a été beaucoup dit par les
élus lors de mon dernier déplacement à
Nantes mais de manière plus générale
donc j'ai engagé ce travail de avec les
SNCF pour comprendre ce qui a créé ces
dysfonctionnements peut-être c'est une
mauvaise programmation des travaux et
cetera donc là il y a des sujets
conjoncturel à traiter de manière
générale il faut conserver et améliorer
cette desserte ferroviaire n plus le
chiffre exact en tête je crois qu'on est
à 18 aller-retour parinant 16 ou 18
aujourd'hui en grande vitesse il faut
évidemment garder cette fréquence elle
est essentielle et puis encore plus si
je peux dire investir dans les mobilités
en général avec la région Pays de la
Loire parce que je le dis très
clairement l'état a une dette
particulière envers la
région ça veut dire deux choses ça veut
dire assumer et avancer sur
l'aéroport c'est ce que j'ai fait en
allant à Nant l'autre jour en annonçant
une nouvelle qui n'était pas une bonne
nouvelle que nous devions relancer la
procédure mais je préfère le dire et le
faire et concerter avec les élus pour
améliorer la nouvelle procédure en la
lançant la plus rapidement possible
plutôt que de
tergiverser j'ai assumé ce choix à Nant
devant l'ensemble des élus
parlementaires élus locaux il y a
quelques semaines et j'ai pris
l'engagement de retourner rapidement à
Nant j'y retournerai dès la mi-novembre
où je où je verrai de nouveau l'ensemble
des élus concerné je pense et j'espère
qu'à ce moment-là nous pourrons aussi
avoir abouti sur le le contrat de plan
état région qui traduira vous le verrez
je ne préjuge pas car il y a encore une
discussion qu'on doit porter avec la
présidente maena sera un CPR qui
traduira très concrètement pas de
manière éterée comme un slogan la
priorité donné aux mobilités dans la
relation avec l'État pour la région Pays
de la Loire ce sera CPR je crois qui
montrera cet engagement très fort pour
les mobilités dans la région notamment
sur le ferroviaire sur la qualité de
l'air c'est un sujet qui ne concerne pas
que le réseau parisien et francilien
mais évidemment Contu de C densité c'est
important et là je veux remercier la
région Île-de-France et Île-de-France
mobilité qui a renforcé les moyens donné
à son opérateur puisque c'est l'autorité
organisatrice à son opérateur principal
et historique pour déployer des
ventilateurs des moyens de filtration
des innovations une transparence accrue
aussi sur les mesures de qualité de
l'air Jean Castex et Valérie pecr l'ont
annoncé il y a quelques semaines est-ce
qu'il faut un plan d'État je crois que
c'est pas l'état de se substituer aux
autorités organisatrices mais il y a un
point par exemple qui peut créer parfois
des diff des incompréhensions voir des
fantasmes c'est qu'on a pas de référence
sur ce que une bonne qualité de l'air à
l'intérieur d'un réseau type métro il y
a pas de norme OMS il y a pas de norme
européennees donc je pense qu'on devrait
avoir notamment au niveau européen des
normes de référence même si c'est
difficile pour mesurer concrètement ce
dont on parle parce que sinon on laisse
prise à toutes les inquiétudes voire
encore une fois à tous les fantases je
pense que ce n'est pas ça mais je le
redis parce que j' prends l'occasion
devant votre commission il y a pas de
risque à prendre les transports publics
hein il faudrait pas que les efforts
fort qu'il faut faire pour améliorer la
qualité de l'air donne cette impression
il y a pas de risque à prendre les
transports publics il y a un plan à la
RATP qui est remarquable de suivi des
agents de la RATP de leur exposition au
risques sanitaires divers et variés qui
n'a pas du tout montré une prévalence de
difficultés ou de maladies respiratoire
c'est très important nos transport
public à Paris comme ailleurs sont un
atout pour la santé et la décarbonation
pas une contrainte et pas un
inconvénient mais ça nous empêche pas de
progresser sur la qualité de l'air
l'autorité organisatrice et l'opérateur
le font merci par à Pascal Martin merci
Monsieur le Ministre une nouvelle fois
je souhaite vous interroger sur le
projet de de réalisation du
contournement Est de rouan cette
infrastructure autoroutière est plus que
jamais une nécessité pour rouan et sa
métropole de plus de 500000 habitants et
la région Normandie les conditions
actuelles de circulation vous le savez a
au sein de l'a métropolitaine sont
intolérables tant pour les habitants
pour les entreprises occasionnant des
nuisances de toutes sortes dégradation
de la qualité de vie des problèmes de
santé incontestables cela fait
maintenant 51 ans que ce contournement
est attendu tous les recours ont été
purgés par le Conseil d'État validant la
DUP de 2020 en décembre 2021 le Premier
ministre de l'époque Jean Castex avait
engagé la consultation en vue de la mise
en concession pour je le cite engager
très concrètement ce projet le président
de la République lors de sa venue à
rouan a confirmé son engagement sur la
réalisation de cette infrastructure
enfin ce projet a été réaffirmé dans le
3e rapport du Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures en février 23 de leur
côté les collectivités régionales et
départementales se sont engagé
financièrement à hauteur de 245 millions
d'euros enfin l'impérieuse nécessité de
ce projet s'est traduite par un courrier
adressé à la première ministre le 20
septembre dernier Cigné par plus de 1000
élus locaux et acteurs économiques
concernés aussi Monsieur le Ministre ma
question sera simple quand l'État maître
d'ouvrage de ce projet va-t-il
concrètement et définitivement s'engager
sur ce projet de contournement Est de r
Je vous remercie je vais donner la
parole à chaces ferernic parce qu'on va
essayer d'enchaîner quelques parce que
sinon ou merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre ou effectivement il
y a une augmentation notable qui se
poursuit toute ma question c'est de
savoir si cette augmentation décline de
façon lisible l'engagement dans le
scénario de planification écologique
retenu cert il y a des signaux CPER
nouvelles taxes la part des mobilités
durables on l'a dit pour autant est-ce
qu'on est vraiment dans le premier acte
de l'avancé dans la planification
écologique vous dites qu'à l'avenir il y
aura beaucoup moins de projets routiers
c'est ce que vous avez dit à l'assem
national mais mais la 69 et puis surtout
si je regarde ligne par ligne je parle
pas des CP qui restent de l'hypothèse
tout ce qui concerne le routier garde
son importance voire augmente au total
les crédits destinés à la route et
consacrés aux infrastructures routières
sont globalement stables en Euroc
constant donc pas de net changement de
ce côté-là pour le rail on n'a pas le
début construit des éléments tangibles
basculant dans le plan de 100 milliards
mais déjà dans les 25 30 milliards d'ici
2027 en février la première ministre
nous annonçait que la déclinaison opér
rtionnel du plan d'avenir serait constru
d'ici l'été manifestement on n'y est pas
encore les 300 millions on a vu c'est de
l'abondement supplémentaire du fond de
concours du groupe SNCF donc au regard
de la planification écologique a engagé
n'est-ce pas plutôt en fait un budget
d'attente notre remarquable rapporteur a
parl de progression de petit pas en
manque d'arbitrage déterminant
nécessaire à la loi de programmation
pruannuelle besoin des AOM pour financer
les services intenses de leur CERM la
question du vm au-delà de Paris et la
première couronne les 5 milliards d'ici
2030 pour régénérer moderniser le réseau
le déblocage des freins ferroviaires et
l' actionner le pollueur payur
significativement pour le kérosè
notamment merci la parole est à Éric
Golde merci président monsieur le
ministre vous êtes venu à Clermont
récemment pour les Rencontres Nationales
du transport public et pour le comité de
suivi de la ligne Tet parisclermont vous
avez pu mesurer les fortes attentes des
usagers de cette ligne des attentes qui
sont évidemment légitimes leur patience
est trop souvent mise à rue d'épreuves
le temps de trajet ne progresse pas euh
il s'est même dégradé en quelques
décennies et les incidents se répètent
irrégularité suppression de train
matériel inadapté et vieillissant
Clermont est aujourd'hui la seule ville
chef-lieu de département à être aussi
mal reliée à la capitale alors le schéma
directeur de la ligne porté par l'État
et la SNC et SNCF réseau prévoit
d'importants travaux de remise à niveau
et de modernisation de la voie ferré
pour près de 900 millions d'euros
d'autre part le renouvellement des rames
est prévu avec le matériel oxygène qui
derait qui devait arriver fin 2023 on
parle aujourd'hui d'une livraison
largement différée alors même si vous
avez déjà abordé ces éléments dans dans
vos différents propos vous pouvez
m'apporter des éléments de calendrier
précis et nous rassurer sur le budget et
la disponibilité des crédits je vous
remercie la parole est à Jean-Claude
anglar merci monsieur le Président alors
ma première question on va poursuivre
celle de notre collègue r gold puisqu'il
a parlé de Paris Orléan Paris Orléan
Clermont pardon et donc aller jusqu'à
rodè puisque le train de nuit de Paris
rodess est une vraie catastrophe et l'an
passé je vous avais posé la question
vous m'avez dit que vous étiez en train
de regarder notamment sur le
renouvellement de matériel donc est-ce
que vous voulez nous donner un
calendrier pour poursuivre la question
des rold sur cette ligne Paris Rodes
train de nuit notamment et mon deuxième
sujet c'est la route c'est la RN88 euh
entre rodè n'est-ce pas et svera le
château le chénon sverac d'avyon le
chénon manquant qui reste à compléter
puisque l'État vient de concéder à la
fois à la région Occitanie et au
département ce tronçon et le département
a pris l'engagement de réaliser les
travaux c'est une un itinéraire
particulièrement accidentogène encore la
semaine passée deux décès donc il à peu
près un à deux décès par semaine sur
cette ancienne nationale qui doit être
transformé n'est-ce pas en deux fois de
voix donc je rappelle que la région
s'est engagée que le département MRE
d'ouvrage s'est engagé et il reste plus
que la participation de l'État et je
sais que vous y travaillez est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire par rapport au
contrat de plan état région où vous en
êtes merci la parole est à Franck dersin
puis après à Jean-Pierre corbiset oui
monsieur le ministre bon la plupart de
mes questions ont eu un commencement de
réponse il m'en reste une c'est sur le
fret ferroviaire et la situation de SNCF
Fred tout le monde sait ce qui se passe
les injonctions de l'Europe le déficit
des SNCF fret comment voyez-vous la
situation de SNCF fret dans les mois à
venir moi ça m'apporte beaucoup j'ai
trois ports très importants qui
utilisent le le fret et j'ai besoin un
peu de savoir comment les choses vont
s'orienter
merci la parole est à Jean-Pierre
corbiset oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre il y a il y a un an
le président de la République a annoncé
sa volonté de relancer les air
métropolitain et volonté traduite par
des premiers engagements financiers
présentés lors du récent conseil de la
planification écologique le projet de
service express métropolitain de
l'étoile de Lille est inscrit dans ses
financements et en tant qu'élu des Haut-
France je ne peux que m'en féliciter il
s'agit au-delà de la création d'une voie
entre l'île et ninbaumont nécessaire
pour désengorger les autoroutes et voie
rapides reliant lî au bass Saint- minier
mais aussi de créer une nouvelle gare à
Lille l'enveloppe annoncée dans le cadre
de la négociation du contrat de plan
état région a est estimé à 700 millions
d'euros de subvention de la part de
l'État sur un projet qui va varier entre
7 et 9 milliards pouvez-vous
effectivement nous confirmer que cette
premier ce premier versement permettra
de lancer les études préalables et les
premiers investissements et que le
ministère continuera à suivre ce projet
dans le temps ma deuxème question est
comme mon prédécesseur concernant le
frit ferroviaire puisque dans mon
département j'ai j'ai une plateforme
multimodale trimodale Delta 3 qui est le
terminus des trains de la soie qui vont
de la Chine vers la France en passant
par Berlin et malheureusement lorsque
les entreprises de mon secteur veulent
utiliser le frais de ferroviaire
d'office on les renvoie vers GIS la
filiale du transport routier de la SNCF
comment pensez-vous intervenir afin
d'inverser cette tendance et d'offrir le
frais de ferroviaire au plus grand
nombre je vous
remercie la parole est à Gilbert Luc
Levinas et après à marieclaude varias
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais revenir
sur Lyon tururin parce que l'avancement
des travaux de cette liaison me semble
difficile à cerner en toute logique les
accès au tunnels devrai être livrés en
en même temps que le tunnel de base
c'est 2030 à l'évidence on est loin de
cette échéance dans votre réponse à mon
collègue philippe Tabarot vous avez
indiqué que le président de la Région
vergronalp envisageait de participer au
financement des études mais il y a mis
me semble-t-il une condition à moins
qu'il l' lev c'est que d'autres
collectivités territoriales y
participent je ne sais pas où on est les
négociations je pense avec les
départements et dans le même l de temps
SNCF réseau envisage de rénover de
moderniser la ligne historique Modan
Dijon or il me semble avoir lu à un
moment que le comité d'orientation des
infrastructures aurait souhaité limiter
l'accès à ce futur tunnel par cette
liaison avouz que en terme de clarté il
y a besoin de
précision merci ah d'accord c'est pas
marieclaude devient c'est très bien oui
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
pardon euh oui je vais faire le
porte-parole aussi de de Marie Claude
sur sur de trois sujets bon on peut se
féliciter évidemment des des la centaine
de milliards qui sont peut-être 200
milliards à la fin on verra comment ça
se passe parce que c'est vrai que les
montants sont tellement incroyables que
et puis le le sujet est tellement
inépuisable en terme de financement que
je pense que ça sarrêtera jamais ceci
dit ce qui et sur des nouveaux projets
sur les projets de développement et ça
c'est très intéressant par contre moi je
voudis revenir sur la question de la
rénovation des réseau existant il y a
quand même des CERMES qui sont
historiques qui sont existants qui va
falloir peut-être remettre en tout cas
beaucoup p de moyens on Contin continu à
mettre des moyens pour qu'il fonctionne
mieux ne serait-ce pour les questions
d'électrification des réseaux sur des
sons qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas étrifié
et comment développer le ferroviaire à
des endroits où il n'y a pas tout à fait
ce qu'il faut pour
alimenter l'ensemble des motrices
notamment sur le secteur du Périgueux
pour penser à ma collègue marieclaude
verias le le plus gros Serme de France
pour le coup c'est la région parisienne
enfin moi je je le pense comme ça et je
pense que j'ai intérêt à le penser comme
ça et ce Serme existe il a besoin de
mément de moyens pour le le remettre à
niveau et la question que moi j'aimerais
pouvoir poser c'est où en est-on sur la
remise à niveau du réseau RER Transilien
de la région Île-de-France parce que les
calendriers n'ont cessé d'être poussés
d'année en année à la fois sur le
matériel roulant à la fois sur les
infrastructures à la fois sur les
systèmes de de régulation donc la mise
en place de nexto notamment et c'est
vrai que ce travail qui est en effet la
compétence d'î- defance mobilité euh est
un sujet éminemment enfin même
stratégique et d'envergure nationale
parce que le réseau est foutu de T façon
en France que tout é ramené sur Paris et
qu'on pourra imaginer tout ce qu'on veut
en terme de de mod multimodalité sur le
territoire national à un moment donné il
faudra quand même passer ne serait-ce
que par les correspondance en tout cas
comme ça l' aujourd'hui passer par Paris
donc c'est vrai que on peut travailler
partout en France et je pense que c'est
nécessaire et il faut peut-être aussi
créer des transversales pour éviter de
se retrouver sur des des nœuds qui sont
compliqu qui a géré mais la question des
r la question de la façon dont ça passe
sur Paris aujourd'hui est un est un vrai
sujet et on voit que CDG Express par
exemple qui qui est porté par des
financements public et privé va plus
vite que la remise à niveau du RR B son
du côté de Mitri Charles Gaul et autres
et je je me fais aussi un peu
le le prolongement de ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure par rapport à à mien
crissi qui est un très mauvais exemple
moi je suis j'été maire de fosse c'est
la garde de surveillé fosse qui
accueille une partie enfin le
débranchement et un travail avait été
fait avec les élus pour euh choisir
ensemble par où passerait justement ce
ce réseau et euh ce qui a été proposé
par les élus c'est pas ce qui était
proposé enfin retenu à la fin par SNCF
réseau et à partir de là on voit bien
que c'est dommage parce que ce ce
principe de de raccordement est très
intéressant et très important et c'est
dommage d'avir construit de l'échec en
terme de collaboration euh sur un sujet
aussi
important merci la parole est à
chevalier
oui monsieur le ministre on assiste
aujourd'hui à un fort développement du
trafic et notamment du fret aérien qui
entraîne l'extension d'infrastructure et
notamment la création de de nouvelles
pistes qui vont à mon sens à l'encontre
de la consommation du foncier et de la
politique environnementale mené par le
gouvernement en revanche il existe des
solutions possibles à proximité et en
province notamment qui pourrait venir
soutenir voir secondonder notamment les
plateformes parisiennes parmi ces
solutions vous avez été sollicité c'est
l'aéroport de vatie qui présente de
nombreux avantages dont celui d'être
situé à moins de 150 km de la capitale
il possède l'une des pistes
d'atterrissage les plus longues d'Europe
avec une plateforme pouvant traiter
jusqu'à 200000 tonnes de frais par an et
accueillir tout type d'avion 7 jours sur
C 24 heur sur 24 dans un environnement
qui ne qui permet une limitation des
nuisances pour les riverins je rappelle
que vatterie est maintenue
financièrement à bout de bras par les
collectivités territoriales et que elles
ne peuvent pas faire plus d'ailleurs au
début de l'année le président du conseil
départemental évoquait même la mise en
vente de l'aéroport à des opérateurs
chinois fortement intéressé alors ma
question monsieur le ministre c'est
tandis que vatri aura besoin du soutien
de la part de l'État pour rester
nationale et prendre une plus grande
part à mon sens dans le traitement du
fret aérien français l'État doit trouver
des solutions pour réinternaliser les
flux de fr en France pour permettre de
réduire l'impact carbone et favoriser
les effets positifs de sur la stratégie
nationale bac carbone de la France
quelle est votre position sur ce sujet
et notamment sur l'aéroport de vatie je
vous remercie merci la parole est à
Fabien merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre quelques
interrogations concernant la saelloire
et la Bourgogne du Sud pour continuer ce
tour de France des projets je voudrais
évoquer tout d'abord l'axe moulin sur
allié parelemonial Lyon qui est un axe
majeur pour connecter la Bourgogne du
Sud-Ouest à la plaque métropolitaine
lyonnaise cette liaison bénéficie d'une
vraie mobilisation des cinq
intercommunalités irriguées par cet axe
que ce soit en sonnellloire ou dans le
rô il est vraiment question
d'aménagement du territoire avec le
dcerrement de la métropole lyonnaise et
le nombre de métropolitains qui viennent
habiter désormais en Bourgogne du Sud
mais le constat est sans appel sous
utilisation du matériel roulant pas
d'aller-retour Lyon parelmonial possible
dans la seule journée ligne classée
parmi les plus faibles taux
d'irrégularité les plus forts taux
pardon d'irrégularité donc sont des
forts éléments de de dissuasion à
prendre le train l'an dernier vous
m'aviez dit qu'une rénovation était
prévue en 2025 et que des études était
en cours qu'une négociation budgétaire
était nécessaire avec les régions ronalp
il ne m'échappe pas que nous ne sommes
pas encore en 2025 mais tout de même
j'aimerais savoir si le dossier avance
parce qu'il est attendu sur le terrain
et en particulier si les travaux
d'urgence qui sont absolument
nécessaires dès 2024 entre saint-agan et
gilurloire dans montcanton vont pouvoir
être réaliser et une autre question
rapidement sur la liaison entre étan
surarou et haain Autin ville
sous-préfecture s de Rome il y a 2000
ans porte d'entrée du Morvent la liaison
étant haain a été neutralisé en mars
2020 à la faveur de travaux puis jamais
réouvertes on parle aujourd'hui d'une
expérimentation d'une navette flexie
navette autonome et je me devais de vous
en parler monsieur le ministre puisque
on nous dit que cette navette serait
capable de rouler en même temps sur la
route et sur le rail et donc j'aimerais
savoir ce qu'il en est de cette
innovation du en même temps est-ce
qu'elle a votre soutien et est-ce
qu'elle va pouvoir se concrétiser très
rapidement merci Monsieur le Ministre
merci la parole est à Alexandre
wiizille monsieur le ministre merci je
ma question prolonge celle de notre
collègue de la somme sur la ligne Roissy
Picardie vous avez eu des mots
rassurants presque des mots apaisants ma
question elle est sur les modalités
précises sur la question européenne où
en est-on des discussions avec l'Union
européenne sur le financement sur la
question de bouclage du tour de table où
en est l'état au niveau de ses
engagements et dernier point vous avez
dit à raison que le projet est attendu
je vous raconte une anecdote j'étais en
garde crayille à pétitionner avec des
habitants au moment où nous avons eu une
grande frayeur au niveau du projet
européen et les habitants revenaient
vers moi certains pour me dire j'ai
acheté ici dans cette agglomération en
pensant que la ligne arriverait bientôt
et donc quand vous dites cela arrivera
en temps utile et et dans de brefs délis
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
et nous donner les les délais que vous
avez en tête pour l'arrivée du Roissy
Picardie je vous remercie merci la
parole est à Sébastien fagant merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre depuis de trop longues années
la Normandie pâti d'une desserte
ferroviaire versatile et pour le moins
aléatoire quant à sa régularité euh
c'est lié notamment à des
infrastructures ferroviaires
vieillissantes à une forte densité du
trafic mais aussi à la cohabitation à
partir de manth avec les trains
franciliens qui rendent l'arrivée sur la
gare de
paris-s-lazar pour le moins compliqué il
y a une quinzaine d'années de cela la
ligne nouvelle Paris Normandie à émergé
avec de nombreux bénéfices notamment
évidemment une meilleure qualité de
service meilleure
régularité meilleure
ponctualité un trafic qui peut
s'accroître aussi bien pour le trafic
passager que pour le fret ferroviaire et
euh évidemment pour l'ensemble de la
région Normandie une meilleure connexion
à la région capitale à son dynamisme
économique et à son attractivité
internationale aussi bien pour l'axe de
la vallée de la Seine que pour la
Normandie
occidentale qui comporte en son sein des
ports particulièrement investis pour le
développement des énergies marines
renouvelable je pense bien évidemment à
celui de Cherbourg en Cotentin pour que
la ligne nouvelle Paris-Normandie
devienne une réalité il faut faire
preuve d'un volontarisme
particulièrement fort les collectivités
territoriales normandes se sont
investies notamment pour la réalisation
du saut de mouton près de la gare de
Clichy leevallois pouvez-vous nous
indiquer quel sera le calendrier mais
aussi le plan de financement de l'État
pour que la ligne nouvelle
Paris-Normandie devienne enfin une
réalité concrète pour les plus de 3
millions de Normand et de normande je
vous remercie dernier intervenant Alain
Dufour merci président monsieur le
ministre je vois vous avez on vous a
interrogé sur un tour de France alors je
terminerai par l'Occitanie et can est-il
du contrat de plan état région lorsque
le premier ministre Jean gassex est venu
donc il a permis de financé la deux fois
de voie en trochz Toulouse alors que
c'est un département complètement
enclavé je voulais savoir si vous il y a
des financements nécessaires pour
continuer cette deux fois de voie jusque
dans les Landes également la route sur
la route nationale 21 dont on promet si
vous voulez des travaux depuis 50 ans
environ voilà
merci monsieur le ministre ou là fallir
faire vite on va faire vite et vous
m'excuserez de compléter si cela est
nécessaire par échange direct ou écrit
euh sur la question du contournement s
de rouan la priorité que vous avez
affirmé monsieur le sénateur est très
claire bien entendu vous comprendrez que
je ne rentre pas dans chacun des projets
autoroutiers puisque j'ai annoncé qu'on
aurait une revue des projets
autoroutiers et c'est à l'issue de cette
revue sous quelques semaines vraiment ce
sera rapide que nous préciserons projet
par projet les étapes qui sont devant
nous mais j'ai entendu très clairement
la position qui était la vôtre les
relais qui ont été mobilisés ces
dernières semaines notamment la lettre à
la première ministre monsieur le
sénateur
sur les routes alors on voit bien
d'ailleurs les injonctions
contradictoires mais c'est la vie
démocratique bon je tiens à dire si on
êre cohérent moi je dis qu'on ne fait
pas zéro projet routier ni zéro projet
autoroutier mais qu'on est plus sélectif
j'assume cette ligne c'est en même temps
si vous me pardonnez concrètement on
dans les CPR c'est un choix difficile on
va le voir sur certaines négociations on
réduit de 50 % la part des crédits
routiers par rapport à la génération
précédente on peut être pour on peut
être contre c'est un fait et donc ça
c'est euh
un engagement de rééquilibrage modal
pour le dire ainsi au profit du
ferroviaire qui est très clair sur la
modernisation du réseau ferroviaire je
ne reviens pas sur les engagements le
contrat de le contrat de performance
doit être ajusté pour justement retracer
et graver dans le marbre cet effort
progressivement et significativement
accru en faveur du réseau ferroviaire
sur les logiques pollur payeur c'est un
peu finalement la taxe qui vous est
soumise sur les infrastructures
puisqu'on fait contribuer les secteurs
les plus polvants pour la décarbonation
de tous les secteurs mais notamment des
moins polvants enfin le développement
des moins polevants via l'affectation à
la fil cela a été noté par plusieurs
d'entre vous sur le kyosen c'est une
négociation que nous menons au niveau
européen c'est la France qui a demandé à
ce qu'un texte soit proposé par la
Commission européenne et cette
négociation est en cours pour une
taxation européenne du kérosen au-delà
d'ailleurs je le dis parce qu'il y a des
efforts qui ont déjà été fait qui sont
demandés au secteur aérien de la réforme
ets auquel va être soumis cota carbone
le secteur aérien à partir de l'année
prochaine sur les lignes jumelles si je
peux dire Paris Clermont Paris limoge po
monsieur le sénateur gold euh mon
l'engagement est très clair je préside
moi-même tous les 3 mois le groupe de
travail pour suivre les améliorations de
qualité à court terme l'avancement du
schéma directeur à moyen terme si je
peux dire d'ici pour être précis 2025
pour les premières livraisons de nouvell
RAM et 2026 pour la fin des livraisons
et 26-27 pour la fin des travaux de
modernisation régénération du réseau je
sais qu'à court terme tant qu'on a pas
les nouveaux trains et que le réseau
n'est pas finalisé c'est plus de
perturbation qu'autre chose mais les
rames oxygène elles existent et je vais
proposer d'ailleurs don vous monsieur le
sénateur avec plusieurs élus d'aller les
voir en test puisque je crois que ça
rassurera sur leur existence et leur
production en France d'ailleurs pas les
tests mais la production c'est un
investissement de l'État d' 1,3 milliard
d'euros je le rappelle rien que pour la
ligne Paris Clermont sur la ligne polte
je réponds de la même façon et pour être
clair sur la RN 88 c'est en effet dans
le cadre de 3DS une des routes que nous
transférons en partie à la région en
partie au département de laavyon parce
que monsieur le Président viel il tient
particul parulrement et nous avons
maintenant sur le volet budgétaire
puisque le département sera sur cette
section maître d'ouvrage à partir et
gestionnaire à partir du 1er janvier
2024 nous avons la discussion avec la
région et bien sûr en association de
département dans le cadre du contrat de
plan étatrégion pour voir les crédits
qui seront mobilisés sur ces projets
monsieur le sénateur dersin sur le fret
SNCF point de calendrier les choses ont
déjà en partie commencé puisque ce n'est
pas caché l'opérateur Fred SNCF euh doit
dans le cadre de cette solution
d'équilibre que je défends même si elle
est difficile remettre sur le marché un
certain nombre de flux de train pour
être clair euh et les contacts ont été
pris avec les clients depuis la fin du
mois de juillet dans la suite de la
procédure devant les instances
représentatives du personnel avec un
délai pour que il n'y ait pas de report
model inversé nous nous battons pour
qu'évidemment chaque flux soit repris
par un autre opérateur de frais de
ferroviaire et que par ailleurs il y ait
dans les tout prochains mois un
opérateur public de fretes ferroviair
notamment sur les wagons isolés qui
demeure et qui soi viable parce qu'on a
besoin d'un opérateur ferroviaire public
aussi il s'agit pas de le passé par
pertes et profits mais au contraire
d'assurer son avenir et pas de
rembourser dans quelques mois 5,3
milliards d'euros ce qui serait sa perte
assurée sur le RR métropolitain lillois
en particulier c'est monsieur le
sénateur corvizard c'est effectivement
un des projets les plus ambitieux et
donc aussi le plus coûteux et donc nous
aurons une discussion dans le cadre du
CPR où le mandat du préfet prévoit un
financement important au titre du
sererme mais qui ne couvrira pas
l'intégralité du financement et même de
la part état du financement soyons très
clair donc là ça fera partie des CERMES
prioritaires parce qu'il est très très
avancé sur lesquel on doit définir avec
le plan de région le plan de Métropole
en particulier et la SGP puisque elle
était déjà impliquée le plan
d'investissement et le plan de
financement peut-être par étape dans les
années qui viennent dans les prochains
mois sur le euh le sujet de frit de
ferrovièr que vous évoquiez
spécifiquement euh je veux pas vous dire
de bêtises ça fait partie des points sur
lesquels je reviens vers vous pour
vérifier qu'on n pas effectivement une
proposition routière même si c'est un
groupe ferroviaire que nous aimons bien
mais une proposition routière c'est un
peu paradoxal mais je vais regarder les
leviers que nous pouvons mobiliser sur
le lyonurin la question des accès je
veux être clair il y a eu des travaux du
coi qui ont préconisé que sur les accès
on décale un peu les choses dans le
temps ce n'est pas la position du
gouvernement qu'on garde le scénario de
déploiement des accès qui effectivement
est un peu en décalage mais ça on le
sait depuis le début par rapport à la
finalisation du tunnel transfrontalier
mais qui ne doit pas être de nouveau
décalé dans le temps et donc la priorité
c'est d'assurer son financement on est
d'accord sur le scénario grand gabarit
maintenant il faut mettre en face de
cette ambition ferroviaire une ambition
budgétaire et c'est l'objet de la
négociation qu'on conduit avec la région
et les autres collectivités vous avez
raison notamment les deux départements
de Savoie et de haut de Savoie sur ce
que vous évoquez monsieur Barros
effectivement le sererme Francilien ça
existe ça s'appelle le Grand Paris
Express notamment celui-là il est en
route et il est entièrement financé avec
des premières lignes prolongation de la
14 qui ouvre dès l'an prochain sur le
reste et l'investissement il relève de
la région et de l'autorité organisatrice
mais l'État est en accompagnement et
c'est le principal objet de loin
budgétairement de la négociation du CPR
francéen que nous sommes en train de
finaliser avec Valérie PCR j'espère
d'ici la fin de l'année sur l'aéroport
de vatie pardon d' vite engagement très
clair aussi j'ai repris le sujet si je
puis dire avec ce groupe de contact
qu'on a mis en place où régulièrement
préfet directeur général de l'aviation
civile PDG d'ADP par qu'il faut trouver
une solution concertée se réunissent je
vais être très clair il ne faut pas que
vatri devienne chinois bon et donc le
PDG d'Aéroport de Paris à ma demande est
en train de regarder les
complémentarités qu'on peut déployé sur
le fret aérien Vaty a rendu des services
très précieux pour la période du covid
il faut retrouver un projet pérenne
au-delà de cette période particulière on
avait on a mis en place les équipes de
gouvernance se sont comme vous le savez
renouvelé récemment mais on est en train
de définir ce projet stratégique pour
vatterie et je crois qu'il y a des
perspectives je suis même sûr très
importantes en complément du fret euh de
roissi sur les projets de soneloir en
particulier ou de Sud Bourgogne monsieur
le sénateur permettraz là de par qu'on
va très très vite de revenir vers vous
sur notamment étant
Autin fraternité ou la sororité avec
Rome implique qu'on soit à la hauteur
mais en tout cas pour la ligne comme
vous le
savez moulin par Lyon il y a une
discussion qui se poursuit dans le cadre
du CP donc là on aura d'ici sans doute
la fin de l'année je l'espère une
visibilité sur le plan d'investissement
partagé sur roissi Picardi je le redis
pour être très clair monsieur le
sénateur
euh je préfère pas qu'on fasse des plans
sur la comète on a c'est une déception
même si sur l'autrre projet on a eu des
financements européens pas sur celui-là
euh et donc il faut qu'on ait un plan de
financement étanche des financements
européens si je peux dire ou indépendant
des financements européens si on a
ensuite des bonnes nouvelles ça viendra
en déduction des contributions des uns
et des autres mais il faut qu'on ait un
plan de financement c'est ça qu'on est
en train de finaliser principalement
avec la région via le préfet de région
en ce moment même d'ici les prochaines
semaines pour qu'on ait un plan de
financement robuste et que le calendrier
soit tenu d'ici avant la fin la fin de
législature c'est ça qui est bien prévu
pour ce projet rissy Picardi je vais
très vite sur LNPN là aussi je veux pas
le faire pour toutes les régions mais
c'est vrai il y a une dette ferroviaire
à l'égard cette fois de la Normandie
c'est aéroportuaire pour la région pays
dealoire sans doute c'est ferrovière à
l'gard la Normandie qui est mal
desservie vous l'avez dit j'étais avec
la première ministre au Havre en
présence du maire du Havre et du Pré de
région il y a quelques mois au mois de
juillet où la première ministre a
réaffirmé l'engagement très clair de
l'État pour le projet LNPN qui est
totalement prioritaire nous sommes en
train de travailler sur le plan de
financement mais je connais l'engagement
de la région en particulier celui de
l'État sera au rendez-vous enfin sur le
CPR occitan euh je crois pouvoir dire
monsieur le sénateur que nous sommes
très
proches convergence pas totale mais d'un
atterrissage avec Madame Delga sur le
volet ferroviaire on a encore des
discussions sur le volet routier qui est
plus contraint pour la raison qu'on
indiquait financièrement mais je bon
espoir que là aussi dans les délais
impartis c'est-à-dire avant la fin de
l'année nous puissions signer et trouver
un accord politique avec la présidente
Delga sur le CPR
oxitalie bien merci merci monsieur le
ministre pour ses ses réponses euh
effectivement je je je vais regarder
comment on peut faire un une quelque
chose de spécial pour interroger le
ministre mais je avec lui sur les sujets
bien bien spécifiques qui concernent
pour que les réponses soient un petit
peu plus détaillées parce que c'est vrai
que là on était sur le PLF 2024 alors je
comprends tout à fait qu'on s'intéresse
à son secteur sinon on serait pas élu du
coin si on s'y intéressait pas mais je
pense qu'il faudrait qu'on prenne
peut-être un petit peu de temps pour
effectivement qu'on puisse interroger si
le ministre on est d'accord sur sur les
sujets bien bien spécifique qui concerne
nos territoires voilà merci mon côté suc
mais je suis à votre disposition pour
donner rapidement des compléments par
écrit ou par oral d'ailleurs mais
spécifique à chacun des sujets pour
détailler davantage et puis pour si vous
le souhaiter monsieur le Président
peut-être trouver un format ou une
audition spécifique à des projets parce
que c'est un peu forcément superficiel
j'en suis confus dans le cadre du
PLF je vous laisse aller on a il nous
reste une question à l'ordre du jour la
commission mixte
paritaire présid